August 2011 and rebel forces sweep into
the capital Tripoli creating euphoria
countrywide the four decades of
repressive and dictatorial rule by
Muammar Gaddafi were over but in a
country divided along tribal and
regional lines the celebrations were
short-lived a National Transitional
Council was established to govern after
Gaddafi's death a year later in 2012
Libyans elected a new legislative
authority called the general National
Congress the GNC was given 18 months to
oversee the transition to a permanent
democracy the deadline passed and
divisions soon reemerged new elections
were held in 2014 and the new House of
Representatives was formed but many
members of the GNC refused to recognize
the authority of the new Parliament
Libyans found themselves with two
competing authorities the House of
Representatives based in Tobruk and the
TNC based in Tripoli the east-west
divide soon developed into a full-blown
military confrontation when renegade
general Khalifa Haftar backed by the
House of Representatives launched
Operation dignity accusing the Tripoli
based government of being affiliated
with what he described as militias with
extremist agendas as fighting flared in
2015 the UN stepped in brokering a
power-sharing agreement the deal signed
in Morocco established a government of
national Accord which was endorsed by
the UN and international community as
Libya's legitimate government
but two years ago hope stand the
political divide suffered another
setback when the Mandate of the GNA
ended arch rivals faced a Suraj Prime
Minister of the Tripoli based GNA and
halifa hafta had several meetings but
failed to overcome their differences in
April after ordered his so-called
National Liberation Army to capture the
capital after making initial gains the
Warlord's forces suffered a series of
defeats in street-to-street fighting on
the outskirts of Tripoli and have
remained there since two weeks ago
afters forces backed by Egypt Saudi
Arabia Russia and the UAE launched what
they described as the final battle is
already killed and wounded hundreds of
civilians and forced nearly 140,000
people from their homes
eight years after Libyans flooded the
streets calling for democracy the
country is at war and divided like never
before
Hashim ybarra al-jazeera